[Music]
all right it's time for truth news the
only news program
you're already a winner thank you rossie
you're welcome um and with me is the uh
two-time winner of best co-pilot of the
year ross matthews thank you it's just
an honor to be nominated
i'm zooming in from hollywood our
special oscars edition our dear friends
and family the fantastic host of
entertainment tonight kevin frazier
oh my god look at them hi guys
hi family how y'all doing oh my gosh
look at you
i mean
look first of all uh cousin drew and
cousin ross well they did it right to
the party didn't they do it right they
always do oh this whole thing
you know i love you guys so much and i
so look forward to these uh amazing
celebrations that we have in honor of
oscars and emmys and you know i gotta
start with the holy trinity who are
hosting
regina amy how do you guys feel about
that triple threat yeah yes indeed yes
indeed drew you were just talking about
the fact that you just had amy on your
show and she's telling you kind of
what's up been going on as far as
rehearsals or whatnot and we just spoke
to her a little bit ago as well and one
thing she said that i loved so much that
just gave me girl power to the extreme
she mentioned that uh when they first
got together and were talking about what
they were going to do some of the the
producers or writers wanted them to do
some jokes that kind of put pitted them
against each other or like showed them
in a competitive light and she said all
three of them said no
absolutely not we're getting up there
with a sisterhood we're gonna celebrate
and it's going to be an amazing night i
cannot wait for these three ladies to
take that stage and wreck it i'm ready
let's bring it let's bring it well
speaking of winners
you want to talk about some of the
nominees yes all right oh yeah let's get
right into it let's start with the
biggie best picture of the year and here
are the nominees all right kevin
michelle who is gonna win this dying to
hear what you think okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna take this one first um i'm going
with my heart on this not with my head
just so you all know and i
loved west side story so so so much i
love the musical steven spielberg was
amazing ariana dubose is like the
darling of this awards season and i just
feel like oscar voters will love this
film so much as well um okay that's
interesting i would not be upset by that
no you would not steven spielberg was
kind enough and we were on our we had
just watched uh the opening trailer of
his latest film in westwood um because
he needed to do his research and make
sure the trailer was playing well and
then the movie footloose started and i
was like this looks so fun and he was
like no no we're going home and i was
like
why i was like i don't know eight nine
and he was like we're going home i'm
showing you west side story
and that's the film i want to teach you
about tonight
and so this is very personal for me and
so i would love uh poetically to see
that film and him win
um and funny enough my heart is also
with some coda action i do really love
that film it's a beautiful movie
um
and rossi and kevin head and heart what
do you want to win well my heart is with
coda because it's the movie that made me
cry this year if you haven't seen it
it's an apple film um and it really is
so beautiful but my head is thinking
power of the dog is going to win because
it has it won the golden globe it's won
all the critics awards
and it would be the first netflix film
to win best picture kevin thoughts
um you know what i i loved this year and
i go with my heart too
i loved king richard
and this is because i'm a sports guy who
has covered venus and serena and watched
their entire rise and so this movie to
me was special and different i thought
will was brilliant now i don't think
that it will win either i do think the
power of the dog will win
and um but my heart is with king richard
yeah and and i would not be sad if west
side story or coda won either yeah and
if coda were to win a little fun fact
there it would be the first film in 87
years that wasn't nominated for either
best director or best editing to win so
that would be you know that that would
be really interesting if that did it
would make history in that fact and this
year does seem like it's primed for an
upset so who knows who's going to win
but we did ask our viewers to weigh in
on best picture you want to see the
results here they are they picked
west side story come on viewers yes
with doom close behind now you know
kevin and michelle oh because we've also
done the grammys together yeah right yes
and we got to do that this year our
audience i have to say
has been 90 of the time correct right
yeah
[Applause]
our audience is on point all right we
gotta talk the newest oscar category
this one has my heart like i love it
business right so fan favorite
boy
thank you to the academy for bringing
this up um it's the first time ever in
history i don't think it will be the
last it's a full write-in category fans
get to vote for any movie
what do you think the fans are gonna do
this year guys
there's no other film to pick other than
spider-man
that's what they say
okay so our audience voted and let's see
what led the pack
yep spider-man was 73 no surprise there
[Music]